[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos vamos
a iniciar el reino unido donde
investigadores están analizando si a las
mujeres les interesa realizarse una
prueba de saliva para detectar
genéticamente el riesgo en el que están
de contraer cáncer de seno ella es el
fort cada tres años debe pasar por
exámenes considerablemente incómodos
para determinar que no sufra esa
enfermedad hoy haremos dos imágenes de
cada centro una desde arriba y otra
desde el costado pero también está
participando en este estudio
internacional que busca revolucionar la
forma en la que las mujeres son
examinadas y tratadas por cáncer de mama
las participantes dan una muestra de
saliva y cuentan sus antecedentes
familiares la muestra se analiza para
buscar genes relacionados con el cáncer
y así se emite un resultado que
determina el factor de riesgo es muy
emocionante ser parte de algo así tan
innovador es observar tus genes para
determinar cuál podría ser el factor de
riesgo los médicos buscan que estas
pruebas permitan ofrecer una atención
mejorada y más personalizada es decir
que las mujeres con menos riesgo puedan
continuar con sus exámenes cada tres
años pero al mismo tiempo que quienes si
tienen factores genéticos tengan un
acompañamiento más constante y
ahora estoy en un sistema en el que me
controlarán cada año en lugar de cada
tres años ahora puedo tomar decisiones
sobre las otras partes de mi vida que
puedo controlar como ya sabes el estilo
de vida el ejercicio intentar para
mantenerme tan activo como pueda
los responsables del estudio explican
que no solo permite identificar a las
mujeres en riesgo sino saber si a las
mujeres les interesa conocer su
predisposición genética pues sería
incorrecto suponer que todas están
interesadas en conocer los resultados
indican que en muchas mujeres podría
aumentar la ansiedad no obstante
resaltan que en una enfermedad como el
cáncer de mama un diagnóstico preventivo
oa tiempo es fundamental
dejamos este tema y vamos hasta islandia
donde se encuentra la mayor fábrica del
mundo destinada a capturar el gas
carbónico del aire y transformarlo en
roca este es un proyecto piloto llamado
orca y fue lanzado en septiembre pasado
la instalación cuenta con 1700 metros
cuadrados los responsables explican que
utilizan 8 contenedores marítimos que
están superpuestos de dos en dos
formando la estructura que ven en las
imágenes el aire es absorbido por el
frente y purificado y expulsado por
detrás
hay un material filtrante muy selectivo
dentro de nuestros contenedores que
atrapa las moléculas de co2 tan pronto
el filtro está lleno lo cerramos y lo
calentamos alrededor de 100 grados
los responsables explican que esa alta
temperatura permite liberar el gas puro
es entonces cuando se transportan por
una tubería subterránea más de tres
kilómetros hasta unos inyectores luego
se disuelve en agua y se inyecta a alta
presión en roca basáltica esa roca que
es porosa como una esponja absorbe el
gas carbónico que se solidifica en
contacto con el magnesio y el hierro que
son propios del basalto
óxido de carbono que ir a esta roca va a
librar metales y formar un mineral de
calcita como éste
lo que vamos a formar en el subsuelo se
va a ver más como esto a
todos los pequeños puntos blancos son
mineral de calcita es decir dióxido de
carbono que se ha transformado en roca
los expertos exponen que esta técnica
permite acelerar a menos de dos años un
proceso natural llamado mineralización
que normalmente toma cientos de miles de
años y añaden que se trata de la forma
más estable y segura de almacenar
carbono actualmente recordemos que la
absorción y almacenamiento de gas
carbónico en el subsuelo es una de las
técnicas promovidas por el grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático de la onu para contener
el calentamiento global finalizamos con
una curiosa iniciativa del programa de
naciones unidas para el desarrollo que
busca llamar la atención a actuar contra
el cambio climático y para ello nos
llevan a la prehistoria los dinosaurios
se extinguieron hace más de 60 millones
de años pero él es frankie y esto es lo
que nos pide escuchen todos van a ser un
desastre
cada año los gobiernos gastan miles de
millones en subsidios a los combustibles
fósiles imaginen si nosotros hubiéramos
gastado miles de millones cada año
subsidiando meteoritos esto es lo que
están haciendo ahora mismo en el mundo
hay mucha gente viviendo en la pobreza
no creen que ayudarlos tendré más
sentido que no sé pagar por la
desaparición de su propia especie ahora
mismo tienen una gran oportunidad
mientras reconstruyen sus economías y se
recuperan de esta pandemia
así que esta es mi ideal loca
no elijan la extinción salven a su
especie antes de que sea demasiado tarde
es hora de que ustedes humanos dejen de
poner excusas comiencen a hacer cambios
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
recuerden que pueden repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom los invitamos a
continuar con nosotros que hay más aquí
en france 24
[Música]
a